تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا لمناقشه
اعلان القوات الاوكرانيه اختراق خط الدفاع
الاول القوات الروسيه فيزا معنى اللواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
سيره اللواء هناك حديث عن ان بريطانيا
وكذلك فرنسا زودت اوكرانيا باسلحه جديده
قرب تزويد امريكا ايضا اوكرانيا باسلحه
جديده الحديث عن ضروره ان تاتي صواريخ
تروس الان من المانيا هل يغير كل هذا من
المعادله في هذه الحرب
بالتاكيد سيكون تغيير لكن هذا التغيير
مستوى هذا التغيير مرتبط بعده عوامل عندما
نتحدث عن صواريخ توريس نتحدث عن صواريخ
بداها يصل الى تقريبا 500 كيلو متر راس
متفجر 450 كيلو متر يعمل باكثر من نظام
اهمها النظام المتطابق مع الجغرافيه الارض
ويعمل عبر الاقمار الصناعيه ولديه القدره
على اختراق التحصينات وبالتالي الان تصبح
دائره العمليات نصف قطرها يزداد خاصه اذا
قسناه مع ما هو متاح اخر ما وصلهم ظل
العاصفه 350 كيلو متر وبالتالي نعم سيحدث
فرقا ولكن هذا الفرق يعتمد على الكميه
التي ستصل وما هي اليه الاطلاق او
الاستخدام هل الطائرات يجب ان تكون
الطائرات المملوكه حاليا قادره على حمل ان
هذا مصمم اصلا لانواع محدده من الطائرات
وتم اجراء تعديل بالتنسيق مع كوريا
ليحمل على طائرات اف 15 اذا لابد من توفر
الاعداد الكافيه
وتجهيز الطائرات للاستخدام لكن اذا ما
توفرت هذه الشروط سيحدث تاثيرا على الاقل
في عمليه تقطيع اوصال الدعم
يعني حتى الان يبدو ان المانيا متردده في
تزويد اوكرانيا بصواريخ تروس هذا التردد
ما مرده ما الذي يمكن ان يحسم الامور
لصالح مطالب اوكرانيا بهذا الخصوص ميدانيا
برايك يعني اتصور هذا التردد من قبل
المانيا
ليس المره الاولى كان هناك تردد واضح قبل
تسليم دبابات اليوبارد وكانت الحجه ان
الاعداد المتاحه للجيش الالماني محدوده
جدا وبعد ذلك وافقت وسلمت كان هناك تردد
امريكي على قذائف امارس ثم وافقت تردد
امريكي على ابرز دعيني اقول التصعيد في
ارض المعركه وعدم تحقيق النجاح المطلوب في
الهجوم المضاد وان حقق بعض الانجازات
التعبويه ستدفع الغرب الى الموافقه لانه
لا يمكن ان يسمحوا لروسيا ان تنتصر وتكسب
الحرب بعد كل هذه المعاناه وبعد هذه
الاشهر من القتال اذا حتى وان كان هناك
ترددا حاليا سيكون بعد فتره وجيزه هناك
موافقه هكذا ما اقرا وهذا سيعني بالضروره
ان الاوكرانيين قد يحققون تقدما ملحوظا
بعد البطء الملحوظ الذي كان في الهجوم
المضاد
يعني الان هناك ثلاثه خطوط دفاعيه تتباين
في قوتها الخط الدفاع الاول تقريبا عمقه
خمسه كيلو خمسه كيلو مترات هو حقول الغام
بكثافه
خمسه الغام في المتر المربع الواحد يعني
15 حزام باللغه الفنيه وبالتالي بعديها
خندق ضد الدبابات بعديها اسنان التنين
بعديها المواقع الدفاعيه وقوات الهجوم
المعاكسه المحلي ثم تاتي مسافه بينيه ياتي
بعد ذلك الخط الثاني الخط الثاني من حيث
القوه والمناعه اقل من الخط الاول الذي
قيل بانه تم
اختراق الخط الدفاعي الاول في روبوتين
وبالتالي الان اصبحت القوات اذا كان الخبر
دقيق على بعد 20 كيلو متر من توك ماك توك
ماك هي عقده المواصلات التي تقود الى
مولوتوبل وبيرديانس وبالتالي اذا تحقق هذا
الكلام لانه يقابلونها في روسي اذا تحقق
ذلك فستكون شده القتال اقل واحتماليه
للنجاح للهجوم الاوكراني اكبر ماذا عن ما
تحدثت به وسائل الاعلام اوكرانيه عن
احتماليه التزويد واشنطن
بذخائر
مدفعيه تحتوي على منظم هذا يحدث للمره
الاولى ويمكن استخدامه في
الدبابات ابرز اذا ما حصلت هذه النقطه
يعني كيف ستغير المعادله هل ستكون يعني
فعلا كما يقال يعني ستغير قواعد اللعبه
هنا
يعني اولا دخول دبابه ابرامز الحديث حول
تسليم دفعه اولى من 11 دبابه الان هذا
الرقم هو متواضع جدا فقط بحجم سريه دبابات
وسريه الدبابات لا يمكن لها اي مهام على
المستوى العملياتى انما هي عمليات محدوده
جدا في الاطار او الاطار التكتيكي الان
تزويدها بالقنابل اليونانيه بالمنظم تزيد
من فاعليتها لماذا لان هذه القنابل لديها
قدره تدميريه عاليه وبالتالي
اصابه الدباب المقابله او العربه المقابله
تؤدي الى صهرها والقضاء على طاقمها فلها
تاثير مادي وتاثير معنوي ولكن لابد ان
تتوافر اعداد العدد اللي في الحد الادنى
المطلوب لاحداث انجاز نوعي على المستوى
العملياتي والاستراتيجي يجب ان لا يقل عن
فرقه م درعه ثلاثه الويه مدرعه بثلاثه
كتائب وبالتالي برقم 120 دبابه هنا نتحدث
عن فرق او احداث فرق على في السياق
الاستراتيجي والسؤال هل فعلا سيكون هناك
استعداد لدى الغرب الاقدام على خطوه بهذا
الحجم هذا والسؤال الذي سيبقى معلقا شكرا
جزيلا لك فايز دويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي من عمان شكرا